vous êtes le spectateur vos amis en
assignation cse et qui vous buvez déco à
l'art au tandem sont madame le pen
les français et les françaises il mérite
mieux que cela
je vous assure vérité il souffre imerys
oui il mérite d'abord la vérité puisque
les insinuations
parce que si vous étiez bien renseignés
sur tous les cas industriels que vous
avez cités vous seriez que c'est très
différent je n'étais pas ministre quand
sfr a été vendue et sfr était la
propriété d'un groupe totalement privée
qui était pas ministre non je n'étais
pas me l'avait déjà comme il se met
ensemble devant 10 millions de personnes
lors du débat que nous avions eues et un
peu monsieur ça peut vous arriver à
poser cette question
évidemment vous étiez ministre vous avez
élan manoeuvre sur l'intégralité de ses
domiciles attendait et mais j'ai décidé
que monsieur montebourg refusé que sfr
mais s'est rendu à monsieur draghi et le
jour où monsieur montebourg a été
remplacé par vous monsieur macro et bien
immédiatement vous avez signé la vente
madame le pen à la réalité madame le pen
sfr était la propriété d'un groupe privé
qui s'appelle vie 20 10 nous sommes dans
un état où la propriété privée respecter
c'est le groupe vive indique qu'il a
vendu ne dit pas de bêtise vous en dit
beaucoup ça n'est qu'une des bêtises que
vous avez proféré depuis tout à l'heure
mais surtout ça ne fait pas avancer le
pays très des meilleurs il voulait pas
la vendre mais personne ne voulait la
vendre sa propre simplement quand vous
avez un groupe privé qui est détenue par
des capitaux privés
oui chercher dans vos dossiers vous
souriez venir je vais vous à vérifier
les éléments et vous est ce que vous
allez être en sécurité en mai le plus je
connais je connais qu'un peu janvier
2015 et devant l'assemblée j'ai pris la
décision pour alstom vous avez dit à du
monsieur dupont-aignan
c'est pas moi mais où parle d' alstom
janvier 2015 devant l'assemblée j'ai
pris la décision de permettre à generali
tri de ramper voilà mais j'espère c'est
madame le pen vous ne parlez pas de
lancement le nord les d'alstom et de
general electric
laissez-moi terminer une ovation bien
méritée le camp de monsieur montebourg
vous avez accordé alors qu'ils le
refusaient la vente de sfr et c'est la
réalité pourra vous n'assumez pas je
l'assumé le mais je laisserai confesse
le mieux
de déposséder entreprise et de faire des
fusions acquisitions ça vous savez très
bien que n ya aucun problème vous êtes
en train de lire une fiche qui ne
correspond pas au dossier que vous avez
cités c'est triste pour vous parce que
ça montre votre impréparation à nos
concitoyens e dossier vendus contre les
intérêts de la vieille folle je n'étais
pas minutes pour sfr quant à general
electric alstom
monsieur montebourg s'est battu je me
suis battu à ses côtés pour que ce ne
soit pas vendu on peut rentrer si vous
voulez dans l'intimité du dossier vous
n'allez pas tenir longtemps parce que
comme vous les confondez les uns avec
les autres ça il y en a un qui fait des
téléphones et l'autre ça n'a rien à voir
il fut à la fois des turbines et du
matériel industriel c'est pas la même
chose